au Marché de Noël de Lille.
Dans le nord de la France,
la ville se situe tout près de
la frontière avec la Bt ans, ple
problèmes de conversion. Ici,
on paie avec une monnaie unique.
- On peut avoir de la famille
de l'autre côller de l'autre cô.
Et, si on devait changer
tous les jours de monnaie,
ce serait compliqué.
- Vous avez le sans-contact?
- Oui.
- Si aujourd'hui
beaucoup par cartes bancaires,
des millions d'Européens
transportent toujours des euros
dans leur porte-monnaie.
apparition le 1er janvier 2002.
- Moi, le petit bonnet, là,
le week-end, je le mets pendant
14 heures. Il pique pas,
- Cet entrepreneur canadien,
qui fait des affaires depuis
plus de 20 ans en France,
se souvient bienportant chporta.
MARC GAUTHIER, Qimmik Canada
- Ça a duré pendant plusieurs
années pour s'acclimater.
C'est pour ça qugasins, on étaié
de mettre en francs français
et en euros pour expliquer
aux gens. Donc, tu étais obligé
d'affiOLIVIER CECCOTTI, ancien .
euro, Chambre comm., Lille
- Ça a demandé quand même
une grosse adaptation et
comme des convertisseurs,
comme des étiquettes pour
afficher les prix en euros
et en francs pour que
- À la Chambre de commerce
et d'industrie d
Olivier Ceccotti portait
le nom de Monsieur Euro.
la transition, il a organisé
de nomiers pour
épauler les commerçants
de la région.
nombre de commerçants sur Lille
qui acceptaient les francs
belges. Ça leur a quand même
facilité les choses de
ces deux monnaies, d'avoir
onds de caisse, de devoir,
après, aller à la banque,
déposer les francs belgesions,i,
les taux de change, etc.- En 20o
dans douze pays du continent
suscitait fascinurd'hui intégrée
dans le quotidien de centaines
de millions d'Européens,
la monnaie unique s'attire
toujouontinue à comparer
les prix avec avant, et
je trouve que ça a sacrément
augmenté quand même.
JÉRÔME CREEL, prof. d'économie,
- Certains secteurs ont anticipé
sur le gel pour
un petit peu leurs prix,
quelque temps avant l'adoption
- Cet économiste rappelle
que leient été gelés
dans les six mois entourant
l'arrivée de l'euro.
de la devise sur l'inflation
éral a été limitée.
- Il y avait ces critères
d'entrée dans la zone euro
les États membres de l'Unioneuro
que ça ne provoque pas
un choc économique.
- Vingt ans après la mise
en circulation des premiers
la monnaie officielle
d'une vingtaine de pays.
La zone pourrait s'élargir
ces prochaines années :
aimeraient adopter la devise.
Ici Raphaël clair,clair,clair,,
Radio